if you ask old people hey out of all of
the ages you have been which was your
favorite which age would you like to be
again which age would you like to be for
the rest of time the most popular answer
is 36 years old I talked about this in
one of my episodes but I didn't cover my
favorite proposed explanation as to why
36 is such a popular age to be it's kind
of weird right like wouldn't you rather
go back to being in your 20s or like
wouldn't it be cool to go back to being
your old care free 9-year-old self well
here's the thing if you interview people
who are 36 right now they tend to be not
that happy they tend to be quite
stressed out actually they they they
tend to feel quite burdened by
responsibility and it could be that when
we look back at times when we had a lot
of obligations and responsibilities the
contemporaneous stress has evaporated
and what's left is a recognition of just
how useful and needed and how much
depended upon us in those moments